j'ai fait la collection de pots tout
fumeur des cils verdez et vous gilles
verlant geraldine james irvine
ouais c'est moi bah non oui mais des
peines avait combien chez vous une
quinzaine mais des ponts fasse une belle
collection et pantoufles donne
[Musique]
regardez ce grand tableau qui apparaît
il y a le secret de tous les
chroniqueurs car chacun en a un et vous
allez devoir attribuer le secret à un
chroniqueur j'étais huissier de justice
j'ai proposé une star du cinéma de
coucher avec moi j'ai une cicatrice sur
la fesse gauche encore benjamin ça
suffit aux mamans on va pas le regarder
à chaque fois j'ai fait partie d'un
groupe de rap je fais la collection de
pantoufles j'étais enfant de choeur je
suis allergique aux cochons d'inde
j'étais un des plus grands fans des to
be free situe sista christophe carrière
christophe carrière ce que vous avez été
vicitme alors pas du tout j'ai eu
affaire à eux mais pas du tout l'ancien
jerry dunn
je vous donne un indice il est souvent
bronzer
avec diplôme ah oui vous avez exercé
absolument sûrs c'est à libourne près de
bordeaux c'était incroyable truc c'était
cela dit on a besoin d utile du style je
veux y aller il était un très beau
métier où j'ai beaucoup appris mais
c'est vrai que j'ai préféré le quitter
très vite et sa première saisie c'était
un point soleil c'est long bravo
j'ai bien pu dire vient de coucher avec
moi qui aurait pu dire sacristain alors
attention de rivière noter que dans la
question
g il n'a fait que proposez vous allez
c'est pas fait tilt oui well concept est
ce qu'on peut avoir fait deux trucs
staff christophe facebook mais alors
totalement involontairement qui était la
star alors c'est un homme justement oui
on perd un aveu en fait c'était mike
myers qui joue dans austin powers et il
se trouve que quand j'ai démarré ce
métier moi j'ai pas mon bac j'ai rien je
n'ai pas fait d'études et je ne savais
pas parler anglais mais judicieux
évidemment j'ai dit à tout le monde
quand je parle anglais y avait pas de
problème donc jean tu as vu max mayer
[Applaudissements]
vient comment avec dés l'âge on se
demande toujours s'il n'arrêtait pas de
me faire des vannes et jules monde d'où
lui vient cette envie de me faire rire
ah ouais et alors me faire rire doigt un
mec mille enfants et n'était pas un mec
me love d'accord et la panique avec
l'attaché de presse pour énoncer des
routes coupées pour à l'interview vous
me faites dans ce registre de ne plus
faire ce jeu troisième j'ai une
cicatrice sur le facebook c'est vous la
jeunesse et sous la fesse c'est vraiment
une grosse cicatrice au bon sens et à la
loterie
en fait quand j'étais petit quand je
suis né eelv ont failli me laisser
tomber et la sage-femme à rattraper
comme ça avec ses deux doigts
c'était mon jour c'était illégal couché
par wolverine ce que ça c'est vrai que
moi la photo elle m'a planté saison dans
l'uniforme à bout de fesse ou s'explique
et vous savez c'est une histoire vraie
que moi quand mon jeu plus si c'est mon
fils ou ma fille a accouché aude est
arrivé et on nous a dit on va pouvoir
coucher tout de suite pourquoi parce que
l'enfant de monsieur castaldi qui
toujours pas sorti il va falloir qu'ils
se sentent bien et on a attendu devant
la porte qui veuille bien rendu compte
assez peu de petites anecdotes de merde
alors j'ai fait la collection de
pantouflard des cils vers des évangiles
perdant géraldine gérer si grave in
ouais c'est moi alors oui mais des
peines avait combien chez vous quinzaine
mais des pompes à cette belle collection
et pantoufles d'hommes
c'est même pas des collections a dépassé
ses propres dans tout ce que je vois
c'est pourquoi je ris jaune c'est
exactement comment ça s'est passé on
l'appelait cet après midi bon voilà
enfin ce credo j'ai rien là et s'est
trouvé un truc parce que je suis embêté
lévy demande aux attaques à dire je
collectionnais pente où elles font mal
et pantoufles en velours à l'intérieur
elles sont mal classées elles sont soit
des glands soit des broderies dossier
des gants et non oui de suivre ces mots
tu ne sais quel aiglons girolles je sais
que c'est du lourd
les cochons dance et vous maxime cet
allergique non je suis allergique à rien
du tout à ce colloque était là j'ai
beaucoup joué les tests en forme elle ça
leur urine qui sèche et qui émet des
particules dans l'air qui me rendent
complexe et nous fait uriner dessus par
des cochons surtout c'est ça que rosa
sèche alors une vraie europe et alors là
c'est terrible mais c'est arrive souvent
les cochons d'inde et ben j'en avais on
a fait des tests formel j'ai été voir de
nombreux professeurs de danse c'est du
foutage de gueule franchement
[Musique]